[Music]
Titanic is returning to theaters for its
25th anniversary giving dudes everywhere
an easy way to seal the deal this
Valentine's Day now settle in for a
remastered honest trailer of the one we
made back in 2012 because some things
have changed since then but honestly not
that much together their Undying Love
made James Cameron filthy [__] Rich
Titanic 2023 remastered Edition win this
sheet of paper survives 80 years at the
bottom of the ocean somehow this 100
year old will explain where the
Priceless Jewel between her boobs were
end in a film that dares to imagine what
if your grandma's rambling stories were
actually interesting it was the most
erotic moment of my life
ma'am that is your granddaughter but
it's such an epic tale you'll barely
even wonder how she knows what everyone
else was saying at all times while I was
being plowed in the back seat of a coup
DeVille a lookout was chatting about his
special nose you know I can smell our
shadow
what is there
anyway back to the sex welcome aboard
the Titanic a ship inspired by your mom
she is the largest moving object ever
made by the hand of man in all history
and that's a big act we're talking 20 30
000 tons tour the extremely British
upper decks
order Isaac the ethnic stereotypes below
I'm Tommy Ryan
and the more people below even them
then welcome aboard young Rose a Once
and Future Drama Queen to me it was a
slave ship taking me back to America in
Chains okay relax watch as the 17 year
old risks it all and throws caution to
the wind because you never know how long
you've got until Leonardo DiCaprio
leaves you for a literal child you're
still my best girl Cora
not getting the best vibes from this guy
hmm Leo Squints his way into every
Millennial girl's heart as Jack Dawson
while he drags Rose into a whirlwind
romance literally come with me Jack wait
come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on
he's impossibly hot hopelessly romantic
and completely devoted to a woman he
spent like 12 hours with tops he even
dropped his Wisconsin accent to be more
attractive I grew up there near Chippewa
Falls and as I was saying that water
there is cold enough to freeze your
pooper off don't you know thrill as Jack
and Rose deal with her fiancee Cal the
Monopoly guy with better hair we all run
to Russ even though Billy Zane is the
only man who looks better bald
[Music]
escape from Rose's evil mother who lost
her husband and doesn't want to live in
poverty what a
hello route with Molly Brown literally
the only nice rich person on board
shine up like a new Penny and set sail
with the captain who is just one void
short of retirement we're tied with a
bang you people can't just go around
foreshadowing like that and expect not
to die it is Unsinkable God himself
could not sink ship she's all the
Lifeboat you need but this [__] can't
see what
up jinx
grab in for a perfect split between
romance and disaster plus the horror
film rule where if you have sex outside
of marriage a monster rises from the
deep to kill everyone you love as the
Titanic goes down in stunning detail
handing out hundreds of deaths that
range from heartbreaking to kinda funny
to pretty unnecessary since that piece
of wood was clearly big enough for two
Jack
I know it's poetic Mr Cameron but this
is the internet you get one small detail
wrong and no one will shut up about it
for 25 years 80 of my body is out of the
water I think Jack's death was needless
everybody in here noticed she should
have got up off that bed and and shared
it with him could jack have fit on that
door at the end oh my gosh no comment I
would have shared the raft
I've never really seen it as a debate
it's just stupid
Cameron's verdict Jack might have lived
yes I knew it I never let go Jack I
never let go so revisit the film that's
the Rosetta Stone of James Cameron's
true passions checking out cool animals
putting Kate Winslet underwater and
using his movies as an excuse to dick
around with submarines in this
three-hour epic that turns a real
tragedy into the backdrop for a made-up
romance a genre that could be amazing
when it works but it usually doesn't you
are just so
never forget
[Music]
starring
The Departed these rows ain't loyal
90-day fiance hey Grandpa um you might
want to sit down for this
girl Bring Me The Heart of the Ocean Yar
leak end at Bernie's Brown versus boat
of Transportation the number one quote
of 1997.
the number one song of 1997.
[Music]
and the number one opinion of boys in
1997. I've thought of nothing except
Titanic
but I never got it
it stinks
did you know that Johnny Depp turned
down the role of Jack Johnny Depp and a
doomed romance at Sea playing a hero
named Jack with a spoiled rich girl
running away from her problems looking
for a mythical treasure being pursued by
arrogant British Aristocrats it would
never work
draw me like one of your French girls I
the king of the world we
this is what happens when you find a
stranger in the Alves will you be my
Valentine Smoochy Smoochy